la vie de jeff chapman a basculé
mercredi soir il préparait un barbecue
avec ses parents lorsque les flammes ont
envahi les jeunes ils ont tenté de se
mettre à l'abri mais se sont retrouvés
prisonniers du brasier
si je suis retourné à la maison j'ai
crié dit il j'ai tenté de les secourir
mais il était déjà trop tard son
histoire et les images de dévastation à
layton font craindre le pire pour des
centaines de résidants du nord est de la
colombie britannique à qui l'on demande
de se tenir prêts à évacuer à tout
moment ce qu'un feu se développe si près
de la ville que franchement ils n'ont
pas le temps de réagir et réguler neuf
et prêt à partir de sa maison de
kamloops même si aucune plat mené visite
de chez lui
la fumée ne laissant aucun doute sur la
présence d'un feu à quelques kilomètres
de la ville
c'est un peu plus tard parce que on voit
pas le feu mais ils étaient entre 5 et
30 km je dois admettre que je vais
vérifier les sites web savoir c'est quoi
les dernières nouvelles ce que le vent
maintenant souffle ou pas du support
sans qu'on a essayé de sauver les mêmes
puis on s'est ramassé j'ai des bons amis
qui ont voulu nous a aidés marie-claude
elle n'a pas eu le temps de se poser
bien des questions hier alors que les
flammes menacent et son quartier on
n'était pas prêts du tout à fait hier
soir quand c'est arrivé on était sur la
balcon en train de regarder la beau
spectacle des claquettes en train de
tomber
mais finalement quand je me suis
retourné en une minute
un brasier alors j'ai dit ah ben c'est
vrai alors
on fait la valise mais hante le moment
qu on réalise qu'il ya quelque chose on
fait le tour de la maison il faut ça se
passe tellement rapidement que l'on voit
là tout le monde loc rider alors on a
évacué avec le minimum
les flammes n'ont causé aucun dommage et
le feu a été maîtrisé
elle s'apprête à retourner chez elles
mais il n'a pas l'esprit en paix on a
les mêmes conditions extrêmement extrême
de feu même chose qu'à l'automne alors
j'ai dit à mes enfants faut se tenir
prêt ici valérie gamache radio canada
kamloops